- You are a magician.
Do you ever do tricks with your dogs?
- Oh yeah, I've actually used them in,
Gracie, so she's a Chihuahua.
She used to be really, really chubby,
and you can do anything with her.
Put her anywhere and she'll just stay.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- She literally just sits
there, she don't move. (laughs)
It's like when you get
the little Buddha statues.
- So a nice guard dog.
- [Drew] She looks like a
little puppy Buddha statue.
- I don't have a picture of her or video,
but I, instead of using a rabbit,
I pulled Gracie out of a top hat.
(audience laughs)
- Oh my gosh.
Do you do that in front of the kids,
like when they'll do readings and stuff.
- No, not for the book tour,
but on Property Brothers.
Every now and then I'll do-
- You should do it on the book tour.
- [Jonathan] I know I should.
- Kids would be like, "What!"
- The funny thing too is,
oh he's, "See ya later!"
- Oh bye!
- [Drew] I wanna pull
him I'm out of a hat.
- He is so cute.
- The funny thing too is,
I'll do magic tricks for the dogs
and some dogs freak out
because they don't understand where...
I can show you one.
Do you wanna see one?
I can do it.
- [Kelly] Okay I want to see one.
- Let me see if I can get a reaction
out of your little puppy here.
- Okay, here we go.
- Look at this.
- [Kelly] Here we go.
- So if you do a
little... Oh look at this.
Oh yum, yum look at this.
He's not interested in the treat, here.
- Well he just ate like five things so...
- Hold up here together.
Alright Paul.
Alright here we go. Look
at this, look at this.
Oh wow, yum, yum.
Watch this.
Here we go, ready.
Where'd it go?
What?
- [Kelly] (gasps) wait, where did it go?
- And now he gets mad.
- It's not in my face.
- Real mad.
No it's right here. (laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Kelly] How the hell
did you just do that?
- Pull it out of the puppy ear.
I actually think this is...
- [Kelly] I am so impressed by magic.
- It's actually the same...
(audience laughs)
When Jonathan...
- Meant for human consumption as well.
- Okay, okay.
- That's white people stuff.
That's white people stuff.
- Hey, don't put me in with him.
- [Wanda] That is so extra.
- [Kelly] That is a correction.
- Don't put me in with Jonathan.
- Extra!
- Correction, that's
not white people thing.
That's Jonathan and Drew thing.
- No, no, no
- [Kelly] That's not a white people thing.
- That's creepy Jonathan thing.
- That's Jonathan thing, okay, okay.